we knew when the Supreme Court
overturned Roe v Wade that there would
be further actions when it comes to
restricting access to abortions at the
state level and one of the battle lines
now is trying to essentially banish
abortion pills as they are called
medication abortions from pharmacies in
all sorts of states around the country
and there is now controversy involving
involving Walgreens and some other
chains related to this the relatively
new governor of Massachusetts Democrat
Maura Healy has issued a declaration
pharmacies must stock abortion pills the
Associated Press reports the governor of
Massachusetts reminded pharmacies
Wednesday
they are required to stock a key
abortion pill despite a nationwide
effort by anti-abortion activists to ban
the medication
the action comes as a federal judge in
Texas is considering a lawsuit that
would overturn decades-old Federal
approval of the drug
Democratic governor Maura Healy issued a
written statement saying pharmacies must
maintain quote a continuous sufficient
supply of all Family Planning
medications including miffapristone
misoprostol emergency contraception and
contraceptive prescriptions now this is
great but there's already very little
problem with abortion access in the
state of Massachusetts but the most
important takeaway is that this is an
action the trying to block and ban and
prevent these drugs from being available
this is being carried out
by a political movement that claims to
be pro-life
when this is actually an extraordinarily
anti-life thing to be doing limiting
access to abortion pills which is the
next sort of battle that they're
fighting now
it's bad Health policy and it's also
extraordinarily counterproductive to
their own stated goals number one
abortion pills are a safe and effective
way to terminate pregnancies in their
early stages when you limit access to
these drugs it can lead to more unsafe
methods of abortion more dangerous
methods of abortion and it can delay
abortion until later in the pregnancy
which is never an ideal thing to look
for it puts the health of women at risk
it can potentially put the lives of
women at risk unsafe abortions are a
leading cause of maternal mortality
worldwide so when you limit access to
the abortion pills you're essentially
forcing women either to have later
abortions or to have more dangerous
abortions and it's a very bad thing when
you look at the health data now of
course the people that are against the
pills don't care and to some degree they
believe if we limit access to these
pills a lot of these women simply won't
have abortions altogether
but we can talk about that as well when
you limit access to abortion pills
there's the philosophical issue which is
you're violating the bodily autonomy of
these women women should have the right
to have these tools available and to
decide with freedom and liberty is this
something I want to use or not let me
make a decision about my body and my
health with doctors when you limit
access to these medications you violate
that fundamental principle of Freedom
Liberty and bodily autonomy which these
right-wingers claim to defend but then
let's go to the end okay
think of the economic and social
consequences of this if you succeed if
you succeed at preventing abortions by
making the pills difficult to access
women
if they choose not to have the if
they're unable to have the abortion
because you limit access to these pills
they might end up carrying to term
and ending up with a child that they
were unprepared for or for whatever
reason did not want to have
you then have a situation where and I
know that this sounds so cold right but
the economic impact you are now going to
have individuals who will lose income
due to time off suffer economic
hardships people who have children that
they don't want to have the outcomes
aren't good for the parents and they're
not not good for the kids and so then
you lose the economic productivity of
that person it sounds crazy to even be
talking about it but this is part of
their entire thing if if that's
something you care about then your
actions and trying to ban these pills
are counterproductive not to mention for
those pregnant mothers who do have the
ability to go to another state for
example to obtain the pills or obtain a
surgical abortion now they are going to
have to take time off
and that's going to have an economic
impact as well so no matter what you
care about whether you care about
philosophy and ethics Liberty and
freedom whether you care about safety
whether you care about economic product
whatever you care about
trying to prevent access to these
medications makes no sense whatsoever
one of our sponsors is curiositystream
the best place to find and watch
documentaries on politics history
science technology nature you name it
they have it curiosity stream has a
deeper collection of documentaries than
any other streaming service they add new
titles every week including exclusive
award-winning films and shows you can't
watch anywhere else I just watched
ancient engineering
fascinating insights into how stuff was
built before modern technology and the
Industrial Revolution you can watch
curiosity stream on all of your devices
phone desktop game console Smart TV I'm
always finding great documentaries on
curiosity stream that I can't find on
any other platforms it's really the only
place to go for documentaries and they
have a special deal for my audience you
can get curiosity stream for 25 off just
go to curiositystream.com Pacman and use
the code Pacman the link is down below